the MLB Network analyst is in Miami for
the all-star festivities he can be seen
today and tomorrow on the field during
batting practice on MLB tonight at 6:00
p.m. Eastern Time how are you HR hey I'm
doing good man
it seems the guys are walking by me
right now standing out in the hallway
outside the locker room or clubhouse
guys gonna see who's that would you give
DAP to heaven cast ed Mills all the
coaches are walking in for the American
League okay and I'm actually outside the
National League Clubhouse we just got
through doing a little tour okay hey
rich real quick yeah I heard you telling
your story about your beard yes all
right
true story on my part my rookie season
we're playing a game in Kansas City and
I pinch run and after the game Barry by
now on my teammates he had a bunch of
family there and his nephew says him
uncle Barry why did the batboy get to
run can I do that tomorrow after that I
grew a moustache get that so that's the
last time you didn't have facial hair
he'll cut it off every now and then okay
but very rare but that started the trend
right there see with that when I was on
ESPN with you back in the day they did
they frown upon facial hair management
did and I've never really worn it for
the NFL Network I just figured between
now and maybe you know the the Hall of
Fame ceremonies coming up in early
August I'm just going to rock it let me
try and rock it as well I don't have a
TV I'd love to see it oh I love to see
it I'll send you a selfie all right I
really don't say that to many people but
I'll do that so uh so how how did you
start the baseball's HR come on let's
get let's get right into awhile for me
let's get right into it because it's
been insane it really has been insane
this year has it not are you telling me
it's amazing yeah this this I don't know
man I'm trying to be politically correct
but the balls flying when I see the
opposite field all right that's what
makes you go hold on now
unbelievable so you know I'm tracking
this thing down cuz I gotta stand these
guys going to take a better
understanding how to drive the baseball
then we ever were
other generation but the ball flying
this year so it's hard to deny well
smoke is hard molten mold says it's
because a bunch of guys don't care if
they swing and miss anymore and because
exit velocity matters more exit velocity
matters more to general managers and
Scouts these days than actual contact is
what he's basically saying well that's
actually a real real truth to that and
you think about it it used to be okay
I'm in a to a no count I can take a big
swing or 3 1 or 3 oh now 1 & 2 oh and -
I see just a bigger swing as you'd see
on a on a 1 oh so that's a big part of
it well but tonight I mean we'll see
actual juice baseball sees I know that
they are they put yeah they put
different baseballs in the inning in the
home run derby you know you know but the
one moment that I remember from the
first half it was just a few weeks ago
when Robbie Robbie Cano with the bases
loaded
hit hit a ball to right-center field and
he dipped his head with the
international body language symbol of
man I just missed it and in the ball
wound up 10 rows deep and he got a grand
slam out of it I've seen a few of those
this year and you know the crazy thing
is one of the little guys I don't have
fun with Cano but I watch us all guys
hitting balls obstacle now yesterday I
said with the futures game yes and when
I say little guys they're not little
anymore
I mean that's the other thing everybody
big it's just a picture bigger I don't
know if it's the food the generation
bigger and I'm looking at a guy like
Cory ray for example who's and I'm on
pick last year out of Louisville and
he's like man I want a little guys here
I'm like no you're not you're here's
your six foot you know everybody's six
foot six five we never had baseball
players this big before you know when
you see Bryce Harper t-64 Chris Bryant
six five and six six and you got the big
man in New York he's six seven you
didn't have baseball players like this
anymore and really that's the norm you
know you got six two six three
shortstops all over the field that that
never happened when I was playing 20
years ago
yeah they don't think they're the back
just because they don't have facial hair
right now exactly how Reynolds from MLB
Network joining me here and then you got
260 win teams here one gets 61 wins
that's the Dodgers with Clayton Kershaw
having a a gem against the Kansas City
Royals yesterday and Houston dropping 19
on Toronto before heading off to the
all-star game which is the better team
how if they go against each other in
seven games right now well uh that's a
really good question uh that the
pitching is going to be the biggest
difference and I think the Dodgers maybe
have a little more depth in the pitching
and it's debatable because the Astros
good for that bullpen it's pretty dang
good but I would have to say the Dodgers
right now our better team I think
they're a little more versatile but the
but for me is Houston's offense we've
never seen anything like this for a
number of years they're that good all
the way through so if you're planning
and nationally Park that picture becomes
a little bit more important and I think
then the Dodgers have them in an [ __ ]
apart so which team do you think can
crash this party
give me one that you think is a party
crasher for 260 when teams that look
destined right now well I think
Cleveland's getting a lot better the
National League it will get interesting
to see if the Nationals are able to get
a closer they get a closer I think the
National League that the Nationals are
the team to be so who's who could that
coach who could be that closer who do
you think would be on the market come on
I'll tell you what I think Zack
Britain's gonna be the guy you know
there's no way the Orioles are going to
turn this thing around and eventually
they're going to go ahead they got to go
ahead and make a move and if you get him
healthy gets back showing what he can do
I think the Orioles can flip them and on
the Nationals that's my number one
target Wow just just sending them you
know sending a little bit yeah I mean
that would be that would be something I
mean but they're only but there are only
four games out of the wild-card Harold
you know you take a look at the American
League every team in the American League
that isn't currently in the wild-card is
within seven and a half games of the
lead so everyone
is kind of still in the mix one would
think yeah but I think when you when you
sit back this is what's going to happen
some clubs this second half you might
fool yourself into thinking you better
than you are and if you got a chance you
may mortgage your future when you don't
need to I think the Orioles are at a
point where they got to turn it around
you know this that they're strapped with
the Chris Davis contract and then you
look at Machado's coming up next year
you're going to sign him for two hundred
million dollars five hundred you know
and then you got Zach Britton
who's going to be a free agent as well
so when you've got everybody needing the
commodity that you want and you can move
it I think you're fooling yourself
saying only four back when you got a
chance to really say are we going to win
a war zone oh great to get in the
postseason to lose the first game when
you could have turned your organization
around so that I think not only the
Orioles but I think there are several
team in that position right now mm-hmm
could it be possible Harold Reynolds
that one of those teams is the Chicago
Cubs five and a half games out of first
place in the NL Central
Wow oh no I think I think they're going
to add if they do um I think the Cubs
are going to end up win that division ma
I look at swimmers back the offenses
that are in that Achilles heel and
here's the one thing the pitching has
not been there so you got to think
they're going to pitch better but I said
this going into the season it comes to
younger than most people think and they
played like a real young team bad
mistakes they haven't played consistent
defense but you got to think that the
team that won it last year you're still
inside those guys turn it around I still
believe in the Cubs yeah I am a feeling
we're going to be saying that September
1st to Harold and then suddenly when
you're turning around and then and then
the season's over and they might be on
the couch a TC at the crib when it'll
come very well could be that's the crazy
thing is they can go the other direction
but I don't see him paying off pieces to
do that so I don't want to see I don't
see them doing that I guess the way I
was putting it is that they're not as
good as we think they are true now that
I had a percent agree with I think we
all thought they were this amazing club
that you really think about it they were
they were
a Rajai Davis funnel it's losing the
moral times and that I can't find a big
part in why they struggled this year
before I let you go Harold give me the
net who wins tonight who's a Home Run
Derby champion tonight
give me your prediction please I think
Stanton brings it home but I'm an avid
not only was home Wednesday but they're
gonna hit some balls off the Plexiglas
in the back wall tonight it's going to
be amazing
it reminds me of the setup when anybody
talks about Boston that homerun Derby
yeah but the one in the watch when that
ballpark was brand-new
well that all-star game got overlooked
because it was a tie it was a great
weekend but they Sam Maguire and the
guns were hitting them through the
plexiglass and left Center in Milwaukee
and I think because we have an aesthetic
ballpark where you can see things bounce
off of it that are flying out you really
be able to see the distance it's going
to be amazing and who's the guy that I
should be looking at tomorrow night that
nobody's talking about who's the
all-star that that is not getting his
due going into this game how well I mean
all-star games pictures in a get enough
stuff but I think the one guy that the
country has not really paid attention to
is Jose Altuve Altuve is amazing player
200 hits every year he's on a streak
right now or he's had three or more hits
in the last five or six games who does
that you know so he's the little guy
that's breaking the odds I love watching
and him and Carrere going to be up the
middle forever in Houston yeah it's
gonna be a nice combo how'd you take
care come good job buddy good child
exactly that good man
beard you got work you got high you got
a helmet album the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that download our app please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the rich eyes and show up you
need that